yo check this out around all this
classic [ __ ] around here
just happy to be a part of this bootleg
game
yo this corrupt check me out on the
bootleg kev show live and direct
yo boulet cav show special guest in here
uh this [ __ ] fly will not go away by
the way i've been trying to kill this
fly for like two days let's love our fly
yo corrupt corrupt corrupt man you're a
legend welcome thank you
thank you you know i gotta give you some
flowers cause there's one album of yours
that i always
just rave that is like one of the most
slept on albums of all time streets is a
mother oh wow it's one of my favorite
albums ever
overseen by daz dillinger i call shots
with you and roscoe that's organized
noise
man you and roscoe back and forth
you know
yeah
that's that uh ray rico and pat
uh on the beat organized noise we just
went to atlanta for that
and uh was over there at the dungeon
with rico
ray came through and then we just laced
it up
sleepy brown pat
how how's your brother doing he's doing
real good
you know he just had his uh second baby
zayalani
i'll call her keolani okay he grew up in
it he got it you got to put that corrupt
twist on it but you know kids help you
to grow up and become the man you're
gonna be
and uh that's what happened with with
david you know skody's on his grown man
now
working on this music still got a new
group luxury click so i remember when i
first heard i called shots and i found
out that that was your brother right i
was like oh my god psychosomatic
automatic man
i was shocked i was like this i said
corrupts brother might be harder than
corrupt [ __ ] right i was you
know what they say man the next
generation they greater than the
generation before them you know that's
when they're doing well
you know otherwise they'll either be
lower
and lucky to be the same but when they
really on their game right they surpass
and that's what scody has done
throughout the years and i remember when
i first heard him rap
12 years old 13 and
i wanted to get in the cipher and i told
him that kickback man hold on
because you know i don't want him to get
embarrassed
and he
rap for like 30 minutes to 40 minutes i
said oh my god the fruit does not fall
far from the tree from the tree
i said wow i sell this boy ready yeah oh
yeah
shout out to that it's a filipino album
you know
shiny it's crazy man because you know
my favorite uh
you know i always say that the best west
coast album probably my second or third
favorite album ever is doggy style
yes sir and that's the album that really
introduced you to the masses yes it did
introduced all of us me daz
nate dawg
uh you know what i'm saying even
even gw got a chance to really shine
warren g mm-hmm ain't no fun he really
shined on there
you know what i'm saying and
kmc became a rapper well i feel like you
have like
quite possibly like the best verse on
the out on doggy style you know at least
like a top three verse on doggy style
wow um well thank you yeah uh i love
this guy no i mean listen man i'm
[ __ ] i love i love you know i i i'm a
huge
you know dog pound fanatic bro and and
doggy style was an album that really
changed my life but like
coming from your
position as an unknown artist at the
time snoops the hottest [ __ ] moving he's
coming off the success of the chronic
there's the buzz of his murder trial and
there's just so much energy behind that
album
give me like your mind state when it
came to getting in the studio and laying
your vocals for that album and just
being around that environment at the
time wow well
you know uh at that time
we all had something to prove
not just to the world but to ourselves
so everybody was in a show and improved
mindset
musically
for the producers
you know dr dre himself
daz stepping his game up produce records
like for all my [ __ ] and my [ __ ]
and
was one of the keys to ain't no fun
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying and uh
you know being around dr dre makes you
step your game up you got to show up and
show out
or get out that was a death row
mentality so everybody was trying to
prove themselves they was trying to uh
get to that level you know what i'm
saying that they was all trying to reach
each one of us had a goal we was trying
to set for ourselves that we set for
ourselves you know rage
rbi rbx myself
warren g production wise because he was
all over the chronic with ideas
so his dads
that's a lot of the voices you hear on
the chronic so on oh that's probably the
most under like top two or three
underrated producer of all time yeah
because you know dads don't really
splurge his he says low
right real humble about his that [ __ ]
fly it's not going away hey he loves us
what can i say hey when you the [ __ ]
you're the [ __ ] flies love to be honest
[ __ ]
i'm just saying though you know what i'm
saying
but yeah you know it was it was great
for us a learning experience doggy style
changed all of our lives
you know the chronic changed our lives
and doggy style
uh
created who we were when doggy style was
being recorded were you and daz already
signed to death row as dog pound or was
that something that happened after the
chronic we wasn't signed
chronic was crazy because suga and dr
dre
had a crazy plan
they only had rage and snoopy sign
and all the artists on there none of
them were signed it was like if you make
it
if the people like you then we might
give you a deal i'm going to give you a
deal and it was like wow we still got to
show ourselves yeah because we own this
album anybody could just leave
and you know so by the time doggy style
came out you guys were already locked
down we were signed after the chronic
crime right right once it cracked and
reviews came back on all of us death row
was like okay
everybody made it well so what was the
was the energy the difference between
the creation of the chronic and being
around that and just the creation of
doggy style
what was the energy difference in your
opinion being somebody who was there for
both like the chronic
you really didn't know
uh
where to go
you know dr dre would critique records
for us
you know he always told me during the
chronic i got a record strictly for you
corrupt i was like wow
i made it right he's making a record but
his album strictly for me i was like
so you know i was excited and just
watching them as they're creating the
album itself in general one of the first
records i heard was a [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] gun
and g thing
and so it was like bam those was the two
and he was just creating as he went then
one day he came to me and said here i
got this for you krup you gonna set this
off
i was like damn let me hear it and all
you heard was what
when
and i said oh my god he smiled at me
yeah
and that [ __ ] came on and i was just oh
my god because this is me all right and
that's why i started that off dr dre
hand picked that for me he made it for
me
rbx and rage
you know what i mean stranded on death
row
and snoop was the superstar so you know
he already had it planned
you know how he wanted it to be who he
wanted to start it off corrupt you're
going to start this off this is go after
that it was lyrical gang bang
and then [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] was the last
record we made which is basically he
showed us that you could take one beat
take all the music off keep two pieces
of it the drums the bass line maybe one
other piece
and make a whole new record they won't
even know that
right they're the same
so he stripped down g thing remix
and that's [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] he took
everything off except for the
key thing and then
boom and the drums
and made [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] and he also
taught me something then too because my
verse
i started off [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] but
hoes and tricks like when these nuts and
sucked i was wrapping it though
dog is all melody he told me melody
and then snoop and dre heard me saying
it and he was like hold on corrupt say
that again
all right go lay that that's the hook
that's that part
snoop add that whoop-whop to it and so
you know snoop came to me say corrupt
say it like this don't say [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] but hoes and tricks don't do it
like that do it like this [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] but hoes and tricks licked on these
nuts add that melody to it corrupt so i
did it like that and he changed a couple
words i had
boom and that was that's the hook me and
snoop and i was like wow so now i got
this record here when i'm having fun i
was a battle rapper
so stranded on death row and lyrical
gang bang that was like right up your
alley white am i out this was new i'm
like oh okay you know adding some melody
into your all of that type of fancy [ __ ]
and i'm like okay boom and i did it and
it was like wow you know what i'm gonna
be a star
then when it came to doggy style our
confidence was at the moon we already
knew where we were going
we already knew what dr dre expected
we'll make sure smiling knows the key
make sure you smile
and know what you're doing you get money
satisfied dr dre and you go
and that was the key to dog because he
knew how to you know do it like this oh
add this to it because he was the he was
the key
so first person to make smile is snoop
um so you know who bam and that's no
doggy style we was all
confident we knew where to go and that's
why you could tell the difference in
that than the chronicle now when we was
critiqued
yeah and signed and we had and science
you had some cheese
yeah i mean you know your guys's
uh group debut is another west close
classic it's a hip-hop classic it's an
album that i feel like doesn't get
enough flowers when we're talking about
classic albums but wow you know that
album oh yeah uh
you know
i feel like after doggy style
dog food
dog father
um
and and then i feel like you know there
was
at least from like a fans perspective
they were it felt like there was like
some weird energy between snoop and
death row
the tupac [ __ ] happened
um but
you you you know
obviously you and daz
together forever but there was that
point in time where
there was that separation where you had
chose to stay with suge there was the
double xl cover with you
left eye was a crooked eye
and suge
and there was uh there was like some
animosity between you and daz right um
give me your thought process why you
stuck with shook during that time
and just kind of where your head was at
i was the first from the dog pound to
leave death row remember
you're talking about because you had
andra you left you did corruption you
launched your label dr dre was first to
leave and from the dpg it was you i was
left i left first snooping dazzling on
him was still on death row so you left
first and i remember yeah because you
had wicked freaking in the double disc
and
but you came back from there my company
antra and did all of that and had that
spin
and then uh sure came home we had a good
chop up
and i was really overwrapping i wanted
to be an executive i wanted to oversee a
company that's what antra that's what i
did with antra i was president of that
company joe marone and tyrone gave me
the opportunity to actually be a part of
running a company
and be the artist i mean [ __ ] i bought
all i think that was three albums that
you dropped on android i bought all
three of them [ __ ] let me do it with
it with my hard-earned money yeah joe
and tyrone opened up that door and gave
me that lane to experience it and i
liked at that point in time
i loved that more than i loved being a
our artist
so when should came to me about being
the president of death row
you know
um i thought that you know what i'm
gonna take this opportunity i don't even
feel like rapping i don't wanna rap
i wanna more or less critique artists
build them
and i want a definite check rather than
because i don't feel you know i had no
well you know music is a performance
based income like you got to put music
out the music has to sell yeah
we get royalties we get our publishing
but hip-hop is fun unless the fun's gone
what you're doing it for you're done
yeah right because it ain't about the
money
you know so sugar offered you something
at the time that spoke more to where you
were mentally at that time yeah and i
said you know what i can do this
because my homeboys
you know was gonna ride with me
regardless
and in the beginning that's what it was
but it you know as far as a friendship
you know it wasn't such a great decision
because it
you know doing that
compromised my friendship
with that my family jazz and snoop yeah
superfly nade dog
all dpgs at the time i think daz was
doing this thing was so so deaf right it
was around that time
that so-so deaf
was after that experience okay okay
cause that's when me and dad's got back
together he was
excuse me he was uh
doing so actually no so-so deaf was
during the time of antra
because dad's got off of there
you know um
and when delmar got off of there he
locked up with
jd yeah i think dog was finishing with
no limit
and
i went to death row to get dazz
off of death row
and so bring him back home so i did do
that and then when he got off
i went back home
and that's when you accepted the
position to be the president of death
row right
and you know that's crazy that's ironic
how long did that how long did did were
you technically the president of the
label
about two years
yeah two years and then
you remember what years those were
uh what 2005's when i got back with the
homies
and we make cali is active
which is a
yeah i mean a moment but but so so it
was probably what o2
it was basically 2004 and 2003.
okay okay and so that was into 2002 and
then 2003 and 2004
yeah because okay so so you got with
death row
after they put out that chronic 2000
album
right because they put out that album i
was still on entre compact what dre was
doing yeah because streets is a mother
and
dr dre's chronic was it was in 2000 2001
same day oh yeah this happens the same
day so that was 2 000 that was 2 000
right right yeah ten thousand now that
was two thousand i think 2001 came out
in 2009 with streets as a mother so that
was 99. um that's crazy i'm [ __ ] old
man that was 99 i think yep 99 1999
streets is a mother dropping the chronic
dropped on the same day so when you come
in and you're running death row
as the president left eyes on the label
crooked eyes on the label right crooked
i had probably been there for a while at
that point well he was there with us
what was you know what i'm saying so he
was there during the 90s i mean he was
there during like 94.
wow crooked eyes start coming around big
c style brought him and technique to the
table i remember technique they created
the lbc crew and um
all right crooked eye is an alien one of
the greatest to ever ever get in front
of him lbc crew crooked eye was a
separate beast and you can hear crooked
eye all on
every record i made
from streets as a mother and space
boogie
crooked eye is on both of those records
you know what i mean
and he was uh
he wasn't signed a death row at that
time right he was just around
right and then he signed the death row
and so yeah when i got with suge
you know crook and i was there lisa was
there left that was already on the label
crooked eye first
and then
suge did a thing with lisa
to do the nina album
and then after nina came gotti to be
president oversee these projects
with suge and all of that you know and
um
then from there um yep until 2005 i
think around then the end of
2004-2005 if i'm not mistaken
you know i told suge that you know what
because i talked with snoop
and
you know snoop was like it's time to
come home
and i was just like okay
wow you know what it's time to come home
mm-hmm the champ call snoop calls over
and that was really about the where the
friction was because
you know
the homies didn't agree with my choice
but when snoop decided to talk to me you
know i fell right back in pocket
as i should
you know that's when cali is active was
of course created that's when we did
cali is active yeah what was it like i
mean tell me about some of the
left eye music that was being recorded
because you know obviously you know she
she passed
you know
way before her time and and um you know
we never really got to
get get treated to
left eye solo like i think we you know
we should have you know so how was how
was the music she was recording while
you were at def jam or death row well
left i was busting
excuse me
um so you know that's something that she
wanted to do for a mighty long time
right
excuse me
but you show her skills
as an emcee
you know and with tlc
it was a different level of music
different genre of music
and lisa really wanted to be
an emc she wanted to show and broadcast
her skills as a rapper of skill as an
she's from philly
so you know she wanted to let loose some
of that illadelph madness that she had
built up in her that she couldn't do
with tlc
in the face right or whatever company
they was with after the leface
so it was like a
it was an outlet to release
this this entity in her she called nina
and so that was like her alias her alias
yeah what i'm saying and she you know
that's what she gave her the lane for
and she accepted it she jumped on and
you know there's a whole different lisa
left how was the music fire
she was fire yeah
i mean of course i mean yeah you know
what i'm saying there's just all these
like you know uh albums we always heard
about to be honest the music wasn't bad
at all you know it's just
different for lisa
you know you'd be like oh wow visually
you'll be able to see where she was
going right you know what i'm saying if
you just hear it you'll be like
because you're so used to left eye
you probably wouldn't accept nina
unless you saw visually what she was
going for what she was going for and
then it'd be like okay because it's
still
left eye
but you know different world you um
go back with snoop and and dazz you do
cali as active
how was suggs uh feelings when it came
to you leaving death row a second time
well i told sug
and i told my brother draws he just got
home
doing 14 years
and um
you know i let both of them know you
know what i i went as far as i can go
here
crooked eyes albums out
you know i did a solo album
y'all can have all of that
but i'm finna go back with snoopy in the
homies
you know and it was time and um
at that time there was like there still
was a lot of animosity between snoop and
sug
you know what i'm saying at least at
least totally yeah so you know what i'm
saying and uh you know
snoop gave me that call i talked to them
i talked to uh my brother draws
first get his opinion see what he
thought he said you know go with your
feelings go with your heart that's what
you want to do so then i went to sug as
a man to let him know this is what i'm
gonna do because he gave me that
opportunity and i accepted it
you know suga's always been solid with
me
you know so
um
you know he was like he gave me his
blessing
which i thought was like oh
it must be right you know suge was just
like well you know whatever you do
corrupt keep your business good you know
what i'm saying and
you know i think that's what you should
do if that's what you want to do you
know you i'm all with you man you know
keep your business up to par
you know what i'm saying and so he
didn't he didn't
react the way
that you know
we i i would assume that era of suge
knight wouldn't have been the nicest
reaction
but he never
came at me like that
ever even when i was a kid
he never was this guy that people paint
the picture of
yeah i was gonna say like you you were
around shook for the better part of you
know 10 plus years right so we we hear a
lot about suge and then i'll talk to
people who
were around him or who are close with
him and they'll say well you know sug's
not
i'm sure that there's a side to him
was like a father figure
i mean he taught
taught us the game
showed us the game
it was
a lot of things he kept out
you know what i'm saying didn't tell us
about but
you know
when you're moving that fast you don't
get to do to say everything or do
everything what he did teaches
shaped our lives gave us a career he
believed in us
invested in his time energy and
financially you know
and um
you know he was he supported us 100
you know what i'm saying
uh
you just hear all these stories like
people were getting beat up at the
studio all the time or there was just a
lot of crazy [ __ ] going on like
you know however many documentaries that
have ever come out there's always that
side of the death row story that we hear
about right never heard none of us were
actually i hear about the good parts
right and there's a lot you know there's
two sides of every corner right just
just two sides to every coin back on me
and you know
uh when it comes to sug that's the only
side that people
want you to see
it's more exciting
he's the easy he's the easy guy to make
a villain in the in the whole story of
this whole thing right like like you
said people pick and choose
the the
credit they want to give him or not give
him but he's the easy guy to point to
and say that's all
it's all what the people want to see
sex money drugs
violence right guns
that sells
you know being
a great person really isn't too exciting
mm-hmm
you know what i'm saying it doesn't
sound like it doesn't sell documentaries
or vh1 unless how long die right right
right right right
[Music]
so somebody kills you thank you
so you know when
well you know you really don't get to
get that side of it
you know what good thing shook did i'm
not saying he didn't no bad things or
made no mistakes right right i'm not
saying that you know
sugg you know grab somebody by the neck
and pick them off their feet
right you know in this business
you got to wear many hats she came from
an environment
you know what i'm saying from the
streets so
you know
he also came from another environment he
played football unm
he played actually i think him and rbx
went to unlv at the same time by the way
shout out to rbx as one of the craziest
voices ever indeed yeah that's one of
the things dr dre loved about rbx oh his
voice was so distinct and his style yeah
and he said stylie
bumped and being found in debris by um i
mean nobody puts it together like the
only person i heard
that puts it together like rbx is the
originator of style to me and that's dlc
shout out to the dlc doc was all style
he's just the way he worded it and put
it together with the whopping one of the
biggest like what is it if he never got
in that accident you know and his sheesh
man
right the big i think that's one of the
biggest what-ifs of hip-hop history
oh yeah you know because man you know
what i'm saying like wow
he was sowing a role
at that time
you know what i'm saying he was about to
be
[Music]
you know where snoop
was and became right dlc was on his way
to be that guy first it's crazy because
see that happened to doc
which stopped him from going to that
place
and we see snoopy at right now
uh
iconic
yes and then the same thing happened
with nipsy hustle yeah
and nipsey was on his way to being on
that level he was man like snoopy
they were just favorites you know dog
was a favorite he came out they they
loved him from the door deep cover
gum
you know what i'm saying
which sparked everything from that point
they already had the chronic in mind but
deep coverage just flew them to the top
right right
you know what i'm saying already before
the chronic even came out so
you know same thing with with dlc
and with nip
you know what i mean and there's others
out there that had that up that
potential
to be something special and different
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see i always have my odd
socks on baby you know what i'm saying
ooh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks these are the
outsiders
you know what i'm saying they got
spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you these are chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20
off of of your order
underwear masks slippers socks whatever
you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kevin checkout save 20 there's something
about snoop i always say this
snoop's the most famous rapper ever
like when we're talking about like the
biggest ever i'm talking about household
name i'm talking about
your grandma knows who snoop dogg is he
loves you
your great grandma knows who snoop dogg
is your dad knows who ev like snoop is
the most famous rapper we've ever had
he's the biggest as far as just like
household name like i don't think
there's anybody who's ever been more
famous than snoop dogg exactly
like period i agree and i say i always
say this i say the two there's no one
who's been bigger at their peak
than snoop at his peak and 50 cent at
his peak
50 was there 50 at his peak and snoop at
his peak nobody's ever been bigger now
there's been people who have longer runs
at the top like drag or
uh you know you could go you know
there's there's been artists who have
had longer runs at the top but that's
their books you talking about rap though
right because you ain't talking about it
in general no i'm telling my i'm a
hip-hop gotcha i'm talking about hip-hop
period like i don't think anyone's ever
been bigger than 50 or snoop at their
peaks because
they had so much stuff going on that
just added to the intrigue 50 got shot
nine times snoop was facing the murder
charge
it was like right it was
i don't think anything's ever really
been bigger now like i said well tupac
even pock man i think you know even papa
park came out everything stopped
i think all of hip-hop stopped i think
snoopy i know what you think but i'm
telling you
do you think all of his do you think
park at his peak
was bigger than snoop at his peak
all eyes on me i think they were all
equivalent they're equal you can't say
one's bigger than the other that's what
people do they want to say who's bigger
or who there's no bigger
when you heard doggy style everything
stopped for sure
you're going to try and tell me when you
heard all eyes on me everything didn't
stop i think
i think that
yeah i mean obviously all eyes on me is
one of the greatest hip-hop albums ever
when 50 cent came with his album
everything
stopped
that's real
that's the peak
when you drop and everything stops
that's
the peak
[Music]
so you can't say
dawg 50.
but i'm
without saying park
and you know the crazy thing is when
big's album dropped
everything stopped
unfortunately he passed away
yeah that second album and then that's
that second the second album he had
already been gone yeah he was gone no
couldn't even enjoy that peak
right
but park was alive during that peak
snoopy was alive during that peak
and 50 was alive during that they are
live
and those three particular albums
i must say it too eminem
you can't tell me what high my name is
drop to everything especially especially
marshall mathers lp that when that
second album dropped the first one i'm
talking about this this is it i can't
talk about the second one but
the first one
i think the second one my name is
stopped everything's you couldn't even
relate to this who the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] yeah who is this
[ __ ] white dude [ __ ] is this she's
murdering people and killing his baby
mama never heard no [ __ ] it stopped the
game stopped right right right right
high my name is was his peak
everything else was a rise
because stan and all of that
was that right when he dropped he was at
his peak when snoop dropped he was at
his peak
when 50 dropped he was at his peak that
was the peak
when park dropped all eyes on me he was
at his peak he was already selling
millions with jimmy i being an
interscope you know i i definitely think
that he went to jail obviously there's a
few artists like you think of like wayne
right like wayne
i think wayne's like he had been around
for so long so it was more like
a a steady climb like carter one came
out and people realized oh [ __ ] little
wanker rap and then carter two came out
and they were like oh this is a this is
a classic right and then his peak was
carter three
and he was the biggest [ __ ] in
the world right but i just think as far
as like just like
i can't think of like an energy like 50
or snoop at their at their peak
i just feel like you turned the tv on
no they
you just couldn't avoid 50 years snoop
you know what i'm saying but but in
general snoop overall is the biggest
most famous rapper ever you worded it
like that you're absolutely correct
he's the most famous rapper of all time
no but when you were at that peak when
you uh worded it like you did about that
peak
you're absolutely correct snoopy and 50
you stay was everywhere yeah and i'm not
saying like i mean obviously it was
everything i mean you know like you're
right as well but yeah i know it's crazy
too because i always think about but you
got to put em there too then of course
where you describing the people eminem
had like 10 years
i think em sold more records than anyone
it's like either him or dragon yeah but
that peak though yeah hi my name is
anger management tour
how crazy so so let me ask you this
because you obviously you know
we're giving flowers uh one of eminem's
more famous verses when he mentions you
and he mentions red man and he mentions
right right that was until i collapsed
right with nate i'm not mistaken yeah
so you hear that
and i thought that was super dope
because at the time m is the biggest
[ __ ] in the world
and somehow i still feel like you're
still slept on because you're corrupt
like to me you're like a superhero but
it felt so good to hear
it felt so good
eminem give you some flowers on a record
amongst all those names like how dope
was that
and i was like wow
because you know you really don't accept
it you know i'm used to being
the uh
the underdog
as you would say you know i'm used to
being
you know that guy
who uh
you know as good as i am on the mic
being a star is something totally
different yes you know what i'm saying
100
no matter how good you are you could be
the best
with the pin
but it doesn't make you a star
eminem snoopy and 50 are stars
you know what i'm saying but you are a
legend you are a legend
you're a legend it's just like when
kendrick
they asked him i saw an interview he was
one of his first interviews and they
asked him his influence and
he said corrupt and the people was
interviewing him
you really couldn't
relate like whoa what
not park not snoop not this one he's
like no no no corrupt you know i learned
you know they inspired me
corrupt and everybody was totally
startled about it i know i was
because you know it's a lot of people
you give influence to when they win
you'll normally hear them say the normal
names
but kendrick was one of the first
uh
one of the first because the first one
was m
you know when m splashed on him with the
whop-wop and then kendrick comes along
with the wham wham and i was just like
wow you know that's enough for me
that's real man those are the flowers
that meant the most to me
because they didn't have to
do that they spoke from the heart and
how they really felt a lot of artists
don't speak from the heart and what they
really feel
they speak to satisfy so they would give
you these regular names wouldn't talk
about
you know
somebody that doesn't make people say oh
yeah
and that was the ooh and all that damn
corruption that list
and damn kendrick gave it up for corrupt
you know that was a shocker right there
very appreciated and loved
you know what i'm saying and um
yeah that made me say wow
that's dope and i did smile
pretty big
um
let's go back to streets as a mother the
bonus track on that is calling out names
which was
another one of those songs that i was
[ __ ] d [ __ ] m only x i know
was exhibitor rbx extraordinary you
could had a [ __ ] anyway
i know the song by heart i love that
song
dmx is like my as you can see i have dmx
behind you here you know the dmx is a
huge he's watching i love x man you
might be watching me um
but take me back to that that feud
between you and x obviously you know he
passed away uh earlier this year yeah um
it was over your ex
or what was what was that what it was
yeah you know it was uh
i was in my feelings
and i was really just upset
the whole experience with this young
lady
and just upset period at the way i was
being treated
being with this young lady you know and
just let off some steam throughout the
time of being with her
certain individuals
you know people will pump you up if you
allow them to
if you let them
and like you know i could say that a lot
of people
you know told me things that i took to
heart
that this person was saying this and
this person said that in this magazine
this person said that
dmx was just the straw that broke the
camel's back
you know what i'm saying to where my
anger was
and so then i just um
i just let it all go
you know dmx is the main thing everybody
concentrates on but
i don't really talk about murder inc
they only talk about
the rough riders and whole
or
the firm
you know what i'm saying and everybody
else that i spoke on oh yeah you yeah
max is the main thing they speak you had
a lot you had a lot of stuff
yeah i mean in the situation you loaded
up for a lot of people 80 right you know
what i'm saying so
but there was a lot of different people
i was upset at and angry about
uh things that went on or what i heard
right
i bought the cart before the horse
you know and really you know things like
this you talk to people man to man you
really don't
voice it through the music you know what
i mean
you know uh the way i was group i grew
up you know
if you really want to smash somebody
beat them up first and then you can talk
about them
right you know
but don't talk about them first
you know and i i was just really angry
what was your issue with uh with murder
inc
no he said she say same thing with the
firm that he say she say you know
person told me this and well cause
that's what cause like when the firm
came out obviously dre exactly to
produce that album yeah and there was
something that was
uh people highlighted in the magazine
and said
read this remember those you know what's
crazy is that was before social media so
it wasn't as easy to just dm somebody
they say yo what what did you mean you
would just whatever was in the source
survive
that was the key to
this records back in our day was that
was the only way to let a person know
that you didn't like them or had issues
this was in the magazine was in the
records or magazines you know i'm saying
your music or your magazines
but nobody was really saying who they
was mad at everybody was subliminal it
was a lot of subs yeah you know and
that's the thing about calling out names
which made it very different because you
said every every you said exactly
right and you know it was only rarity
records back in the days like that
real diss records you know chris back in
the days
with m.c shannon and
the bridge is over in south bronx and
letting it be known
you know and uh then you know as you
keep going you see the progression ice
cube no vaseline
but a lot of rappers hit him up
yeah hit him up pop you know what i'm
saying before that it was all subliminal
like new york new york wasn't to diss
new york
because i don't do subliminals i'm a
real battle rapper i'm a real mc if i
had an issue with somebody
you know i'm gonna put their name in let
them know you
pinpoint them you you you and you
you know what i'm saying and um
so new york new york was taken out of
text and you know yeah that song was
never meant to be a slight to new york
correct not at all and the video
i think i don't even think it was much
about the song as much it was about the
video that was after we got shot at
um so so that so you guys got shot at
and then you guys did the video the way
you did the video yeah
so the video was meant to be like a [ __ ]
you but the song itself originally was
not meant to be a like a [ __ ]
you know the first scenes was in times
square we wouldn't go to new york to
shoot the video i mean we had balls but
not that much bro
yeah i'm saying that new york in the
night is a wild place
guys was cat as was l.a it's the capital
but new york
new york is like los angeles they had
the gangs original gangs right you know
what i'm saying is out of new york city
so
you know what i'm saying like chicago
you know what i'm saying you know
so we we thought actually new york would
accept it it's a mellie mel chorus
melanie mellon the furious five
grandmaster flash
you know melly mel cleared it
you know what i'm saying got paid
so we was like melanie mel cleared it oh
well
dang we finally gonna get the respect
we're gonna get new york to love they're
gonna love us for this
when we you know put this one out
they're gonna love us you know what i'm
saying and when we drop dog food nobody
made a fuss about new york new york our
first single was let's play house
so
the album was already out nobody was
making a fuss like we was this in new
york and everybody liked new york new
york that's why i became the next video
and
we said we're going to shoot this in
time we're going to shoot this in times
square in new york
oh man we're finally going to get the
love
that you know as much as we love new
york new york is finally going to love
us this song is dedicated to them and
we're going to get respect as mcs
corrupt you leading that way
for them to to love
lamb
yeah i'm saying i was like wow
this is going to be historic so we fly
out there we flew out the low riders and
you know it was a big deal to us and
we invited everybody come through and
and let's all get down and
you know come be in the video and let's
show them this unification
only one that really showed up was monie
love
you know she showed up gave us some love
um nobody else showed up a couple people
though we had uh case slo que solo
building he always [ __ ] with us though
you know and a couple other people came
to show love but
you know so you guys had originally
intended
to invite a bunch of people from new
york to the new york we sent a shout out
to
all of new york you know coming through
shooting this video dedicated to y'all
type of vibe
and they really didn't feel that way and
then uh after we shot in times square we
shot in
red hook brooklyn
and you know a couple
shells went through our trailer
nobody got hurt but our pride did
so you know
we stopped everything got up out of
there we got home we was down for a bit
and then we just was like uh we can't go
for this
that's where you came up with the new
video i didn't think we dissing them
we gonna show you this
and then
[Music]
the whole
dynamics and direction of the video
changed
and that's when we did all of that right
there
yeah that was an interesting video and
an interesting time too because then i
know
you know shout out to uh capone and
noriega cnn did their yeah their their
la la la la which was you know
it was it was a it was a wild time to be
around i'm sure be around death talk to
nora about it i think we was on um
we was on a drink championship yeah
shots were talking about that and um you
know neue was you know he's so funny oh
he's hilarious oh yeah he's the best
nori was one of the first that i linked
up with
who uh we became very good close friends
you know it's fortunate that i linked up
with dmx before he passed away
and we became friends actually i think
um
who was up in there dana dane was at the
airport
me
dmx and dana dane all had flights and
me and dmx squashed our situation and
we became real good friends then man you
know i talked to him whenever i see him
he was all cool and new
it was good that that happened before he
passed away get that just get that out
of the way you know what i'm saying me
and nas
i did a movie with ja rule
you know i'm saying half past dead
you know we got rid of our differences i
talked with irv
i talked with everybody that you know
um
that i shot at
uh with calling out names and got rid of
all of that you know uh
all those issues and problems yeah yeah
it's crazy too because you were super
super so close to snoop dogg and snoop
dogg historically like we look back at
that time he had a lot of people in new
york that he was tight with and and from
what i've heard shook was not didn't
like that suganpak didn't like the fact
that he was
so cool with
a bunch of new york mcs
during that time were you still like
super close with snoop and did you have
some of those same relationships snoop
had with some of those new york artists
um
we
was uh
we're still on death row yeah
right so that was yeah that was because
that was before you started because when
did corruption come out 2099 98
okay okay so that was right before
you left
so you felt did you win that was when
tupac came home yeah i was gonna say did
you feel
like the division between pock and suge
and snoop like did you see it like with
your own eyes because obviously there
was you know that we heard poc records
that got leaked way after where he was
talking [ __ ] about snoop you know what
i'm saying like did you see that with
your own eyes like that division like
whether you could sit where you could
tell like oh
you know snoop's gonna eventually end up
leaving death dog pound is a gang
yes
yes
self-explanatory
yes how how weird was that that that
that time though because
obviously from a fan's perspective we
didn't see all of the internal issues
going on right yeah um
poc is like you said the biggest thing
moving
you know two of america's most wanted is
a song with poc and snoop on it that's
going crazy and that is good to be and
daz did the beat and and you know
and at the time there
the snoop and pok and suga weren't
seeing eye to eye you know what i'm
saying like what was that what was that
what was that era like of of just just
being around snoop and dog pounds like
this [ __ ]
that was the error
period that's what it was [ __ ]
right it's crap
so at that like
was there ever a point in time mark was
our friend and when i say our i'm
speaking of the dog pound in general
snoopy
dazz grub
they don't know all of our yeah
you know what i'm saying and the outlaws
and thug life psyching everybody you
know what i'm saying so they was all our
friends
now the two heads of the horses have an
issue
you know
um
so you know eventually
they would have worked that out
you know what i'm saying right that's
what you know friends do tupac and
snoopy were real friends
you know what i'm saying and poc had his
issue
and snoopy was you know
i mean what's going to happen to snoop
right
nothing
if people are smart yeah you know what
i'm saying and
pock didn't want to harm dog
you know what i'm saying tupac love dog
he was more disappointed
than anything
and you know
me and parker similar sometimes we bring
the carpet for the horse
you know what i'm saying and like those
records you hear
no that was pock he was filled with
anger
and he would let it go and those records
probably were never even recorded for us
to ever hear
obviously they were never officially
released like they ended up
it was recorded to be heard
you know but
it's just like me and dmx
you know what i'm saying
you know we
we got together
and um squashed our beef all right right
and we didn't even know each other
snoop and tupac they knew each other
they were friends so that was
yeah what i'm saying so that would have
eventually been taken out the water and
i doubt if pop would have
released those records about snoopy
you know what i'm saying but you never
know with tupac you know he was very
spontaneous and
he said what he meant you know what i'm
saying that was tupac um
talk to me about you know four horsemen
which was originally a record that was
on a
i forget which cannabis album it was i
think it was on 2000 bc one it was a
group
we tried to do it put it together but
our [ __ ] kept leaking
we put the group together first came up
with the whole idea and
we were about to make it reality but
records kept getting leaked kept getting
leaked so we put a pause on it
so cannabis and razz cass took one of
the records each took a different record
it was like well [ __ ] it man i'm gonna
put this on my album since we're gonna
freeze on the album right now i'm gonna
put this on my album that was cannabis
and then brad said i'll put this on mine
i think priests took couples that
[ __ ] don't put these online because
we planned on starting from scratch
anyway everybody was leaking all of our
[ __ ] so that's what they did
to give them pieces of the horsemen
and the experience that we was planning
on coming back together to give them new
records
took us 20 years to actually get the
real
the real masterpiece together the real
product i was just saying like what you
guys did back then i always look at you
guys as like the original slaughterhouse
like you know slaughterhouse was joe
budden and joel ortiz and and royce
everybody came together crooked eye but
you guys did that first as just kind of
like this super group of like just
lyrical monsters you know what i'm
saying that's a compliment thank you
very much why was why why is now the
time to come back together though like
why why uh
like what's the motivation to do a four
horsemen
project in 2021
um
we're a real group
it's not a gimmick right
we was just doing it just to do it
like dog pound epmd
run dmc
public enemy
you know it's one album
there's many more to come
you know what i'm saying took us that
long to be able to get it
people kept you know throwing our [ __ ]
out there inside people you know we
couldn't give [ __ ] man they just kept
coming out do five records next thing
you know four of them would get leaked
that's crazy like oh man
and then you know we got our own lives
and careers so then you know you try so
much to get it there it keeps falling
back
so you know hey we just go and do our
own things and
eventually get back together when we can
and try it again and
you know we tried about two good times
the first time and then we tried a
second time the same results
so this is the third time's a try or a
charm rather right third time's the
charm
worked out swell what's the competition
levels between all four of you guys
because each one of you i mean
are you do you get on the record hoping
to have the best verse because
everyone's killers on the on each one of
these records you know i get on there
and have fun right you know it's it's
fun so you know you get up there
everybody's together or three of us
together or even if it's two
and you just spit you know what i'm
saying
the first the first verse tells you
everything
i don't think we came up with hooks
first i think we came up with
the verses first right bam once that
first one laid first swoop off the next
one comes the hook comes oh let's get
that to such such or if we're all there
it just falls in line
you know we just have fun we just get on
the mic our songs are similar to ciphers
they all start off as ciphers to beat
play and then everybody's just getting
their [ __ ] off
and get the busting like a cipher in
there oh yeah
something catchy crap which is exactly
what fans would want to hear from you
guys just some bars
you know and that was the key to
horsemen
you know we wasn't thinking about radio
records or
thank god i wouldn't want that from
before you know people to people like
yeah you know what i'm saying we gave
him the mic
right that's what the horseman is about
pure and adulterated mic
you know what i'm saying and
so you know we was able to still save a
couple from the past people ain't get
we took a couple records that stood out
from the past that we that was placed
out and then did some new ones and added
on the new ones
razz and m80 basically
forefronted getting it all together and
putting it all together and
they did great um okay so that so go
support the full horseman [ __ ] oh yeah
um
is there any talks of doing another dog
pound album
we drop in august august 13th so august
13th
so that's coming me and dads yup and the
first single is nice and slow we
released some from the album i think two
of them
uh we gave to them
to lighten up their little muskets and
uh
which you know bottom [ __ ] and we
rolling
and then uh we just shot
our first single and second
official singles uh the first one is
nice and slow with me dazzling snoopy
second one is uh
used to with
you know me dazz and eric bellinger
shout out to eric bellinger man yeah my
guy uh and then the other thing is
you know dre has been in the studio
working on the detox in 13 million
iterations of the detox for the last
hour dr dre is a stickler how many how
many like have you heard any of that
music and were you asked to be on any of
the records that we probably will never
end up hearing but like was were you
ever at at all point a part of that
creative process
since day one
since day one oh yeah
how great is the music
because i'm sure whatever you heard will
probably never even in appearing but
like i mean i hope i'm wrong i heard
three or four detoxes
you know it's like but dr dre
you know he's he's a
perfectionist
that's why all his records are just
different every time they hit a peak
they go somewhere with something
different dr dre
it's a perfectionist you know he's
you know you wait
and you wait but when you get it
it's worth it oh boy is it you know what
i'm saying
and so you know with dr dre
i mean [ __ ] man
he got so much in that vault
you know
classics but you know dr dre
is something he's looking for him when
he finds it
i just hope i just hope we like like we
get an album
where we hear you and snoop and daz and
exhibit and
that he
has created so many
like superstars and of course
artists
that people want to hear like that
you know i think it's kind of difficult
to by the way he did a little bit well
he did a great job putting the the
compton album together yeah that album
doesn't get talked about enough that was
a great body of work but i just like i'm
just always like man like you know i
remember before
that chronic album the last chronicle
he put out the aftermath
yeah the aftermath uh compilation we've
been there done that
and then he dropped the chronic
this time he dropped compton
that's fair nice comparison so you know
what's gonna happen
okay
well we'll be waiting
and let's just look at what he has to
bring to the table and then you'll
understand how difficult it is
because the album has to have everybody
on it
this has to have those three it has to
have kendricks snoop it's gotta have you
it's gotta yeah no no for sure
rage
you know that's the type of place dr dre
is going where i can fit in
it's just
all of it a big gumbo
i'm saying well that's what he did with
2001 man it was it was like a perfect
you know even like i mean when i talked
to 50 i was like yo 50. like why don't
you s m and dre just get into the studio
and make an album like that's what the
fans want why is it so hard to just give
people what they want but but but it's
dr dre
how do you get it no he gets well
in the studio and then there's eminem
who's the you know and then there's 50
who's executive producers in all his tv
shows sometimes it's not you know just
being a hip-hop fan he thinks shits a
lot of years and it really is you know
what i'm saying
first thing is
how do you get dr dre in the studio 100
dr dre get you in the studio
that's the key and as soon as dr dre
you know shoots out that bat signal
we all going to come immediately when
he's ready em
snoopy
gotti
dabs
rage rbx
50
yup immediately
you know what i'm saying dr dre has such
an arsenal
his tree is crazy stupid everybody be
right there kendrick
yep
well listen man corrupt i appreciate the
sit down yes sir you're a legend i mean
you are the man ah man so are you bro
when i first moved to l.a i ran into you
at hooters across the street from
staples center oh and i was like this is
a good day
i went and got some hot wings that was
my
my my years of uh when i was indulging
in some good old-fashioned patron yes
you were drunk for sure you're [ __ ]
right
[Laughter]
i had to leave all day long corrupt i
love you to death
thanks for having me
[ __ ]